in a new twist in the search for a
missing missing Connecticut mother
police say they have found some of her
blood in places where her estranged
husband and girlfriend may have been
recorded on camera vote east do Lowe's
and Michelle Tripp CONUS were arraigned
yesterday Molla legi is in New Canaan
Connecticut molla where are police
looking boy Anthony police are focusing
on several locations connected to Fotis
Doulos as well as this public park this
is near Jennifer's home and more
significantly this is where her SUV was
found abandoned as recently as yesterday
authorities were here but searching
along that tree line still searching for
evidence and the couple has been charged
with tampering with physical evidence as
well as hindering prosecution and
authorities say more charges are
expected Fotis dulo said nothing as he
was ushered into court Monday morning he
and his girlfriend Michelle truck Onis
did not enter pleas as they face charges
related to Jennifer dual OSes
disappearance
Jennifer was reported missing by friends
on May 24th according to an arrest
affidavit when police arrived at her
home they found multiple stains on the
garage floor which tested positive for
human blood and evidence of attempts to
clean the crime scene Jennifer had been
living in a house in New Canaan with her
five young children after she left her
husband about two years ago the couple
have been involved in a fierce divorce
and custody battle ever since
investigators say they've obtained
surveillance videos that show a man
fitting photius description stopping at
over 30 locations on the day Jennifer
disappeared and placing multiple garbage
bags into various trash receptacles
police say a woman they believe is
Michelle also leans out of a truck and
is seen placing something on the ground
or picking up an item according to the
affidavit
police retrieved the discarded garbage
bags and DNA tests of the clothing and
household items inside came back
positive for Jennifer's blood the
reality is it's not looking good for mr.
dillos ken Belkin is a criminal defense
attorney and has been following this
case closely
they haven't been formally charged with
a murder but I would expect once that
there is definitive evidence that loss
of life occurred I
expect that they're gonna be charged as
far as Jennifer's children authorities
say that they are safe with Jennifer's
mother back in New York now this
investigation police say that focuses
cell phone pinged in several locations
throughout the state of Connecticut that
may ultimately help authorities piece
this case together bond was set at
$500,000 for both POTUS and his
girlfriend Michelle yesterday Michelle
posted she has been released
Fotis has not still in custody Mikael
the couple is due back in court one week
from today a heartbreaking and
terrifying story thinking about those
five children Thank You mola